Ron please
no no way come on Ron I've been a loyal
foot soldier give me my shot let me have
lot 48.
is that a travel pillow around your neck
run I don't know how to explain this to
you when you've been down in the pit
have you been in the pit
no I haven't gotten down there yet well
I have when you fill in when I visited
the bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission
and when you're down there you get some
perspective about
what it all means
let me tell you something Ron
what it means is
I want this subcommittee
I've been quite open about this around
the office I don't want this parks
department to build any parks because I
don't believe in government I think that
all government
is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream is to have the park system
privatized
and run entirely for profit by
corporations
like Chuck E cheese
they have an impeccable business model I
would rather work for Chuck E cheese
well I will definitely think about it
I like the sound of that definitely I'm
gonna leave before you change your mind
hey there you are thanks for meeting me
here well if you'd have held him here
instead of that conference room I would
have come to more meetings I got to tell
you Leslie establishing this National
Park right next to Pawnee is quite an
accomplishment
this is a fine piece of land you saved
thank you Ron
you want to run it
superintendent of Bryce Canyon retired
and I convinced the superintendent of
this park to transfer shuffled a few
things around the point is someone needs
to take care of this place now thought
it should be you
all right
well first of all I would be working for
the federal government your job would be
to walk around the land alone you'd live
in the same town you've always lived in
you'd work outside you'd talk to Bears
next argument there must be dozens of
people gunning for this job I wouldn't
want you to ruffle any feathers am I
even qualified well a few people might
be annoyed but they'll get over it and
as far as your qualifications you're Ron
Swanson
stop being a dummy and accept
when do I start oh today I already
accepted for you I still remember how to
forge your signature let's go meet your
staff
Pawnee National Park Rangers this is Ron
Swanson your new superintendent and boss
Rangers
my name is Ronald Ulysses Swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as I'm not
looking for any new friends end of
speech
well said
thank you Leslie
you're welcome Ron
okay
time to go to work
laugh with me buddy just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me buddy
don't ever let me star
feeling lonely
[Music]
Leslie nope builder of parks I was
canvassing can't Embassy was okay
but I think we're going to have to
postpone the town meeting
postponed
only for one to 90 days
no you're doing this meeting you have my
full support I was talking to the city
manager exchanging ideas there's a
mutual respect there and together we
have decided to Fast Track your project
city manager wow really
have to cancel this meeting Fast Track
did my name come up at all ah this
meeting needs to be canceled no it's
happening
look just
just do a good job tomorrow okay we have
to push this thing through
of course of course I'll push anything
through anything you know me are you
sweating through your suit I doubt it
it's a very breathable fabric oh yeah I
am
laugh with me buddy just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me but
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
if I ever needed you nobody
you know now I really do
but
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
well this is different from what I
expected to find
good morning guys good morning Leslie
what did you do to the office Ron you're
wearing my yoga clothes they're gonna
stretch out the elastic we're sorry
hey parks department hey Mark
this is Beth my ex-wife Tammy's better
looking sister nice to meet you nice to
meet you
you guys are together yep my ex-wife
Tammy cheated on me then we divorced
then last week I ran into her sister
Beth here turns out she hates Tammy too
so we started dating it's like a fairy
tale Tammy stinks
picture bear what are you doing with
this
Tammy I've given this a lot of thought
we should break up
what's the matter little boy
bad people get
just made me realize how unhealthy this
is literally all the steak and whiskey I
have to wear a diaper gosh because
you're my little baby we drilled you on
this Jam baby talk what do you do
I'm not a baby I'm a big boy
okay well that wasn't terrible don't
listen to Leslie she's trying to
manipulate you all she cares about is
herself and I can prove it how's this
Leslie
you leave us alone and we swing the vote
to you help you get your Park
no nice try stay strong Jeremy
it's over Tammy tell you what it's been
long enough
what do you say we
consummate our relationship
tonight
huh let's do it
and the last card is played what are you
doing this is a library
Ron I need that crotch Blinder no you
don't just end it
my boobs no
no it's over Tammy what to hell with you
woman goodbye
I'm Jeremy
turns out the crotch Blinder was inside
you all alone